what do you say to those fans who are
already assuming that you two tied the
knot
uh they should know that we are planning
to manage this till 2013.
since 2013 2013 we are trying to
and this is a kind of process we are in
between
try to convince the family
bring them together and all that and
that's why my mom will gonna come to our
house live together let's see
this is her idea to come together and
see how jenny
can be a good wife or a kid wait so
that's happening your mama's gonna come
actually this is her idea it's her idea
to come and live with us and see if i
can take care of him or not okay because
i mean the last time i checked
she threatened you smith that she was
gonna commit suicide if you were to move
forward with jenny
right
first of all did you take that as truth
when she said it is that still a fear of
yours or what i cannot just take it is
it just a false threat or something i
did take it seriously and
and after that i keep on trying
uh to show my mother that i was unhappy
and previous married and this is what i
wanted my life
uh maybe it's different than uh normal
couples but we are happy together
and
that's what i want to show it to my
mother that we are we are good together
i'm happy and that's what i wanted
she should come see us together how we
are together she should i know when you
all lived together before for a short
amount of time you two became close
there was a moment where you were
friendly very friendly with each other
are we gonna see that relationship build
again
uh we're gonna do our best we're gonna
try our best to make that
happen once again i'm that's what that's
what my hope is that i can get his
mother back on my good side she loved me
once then i'm i'm pretty sure that she
can love me again she just needs to give
me a chance and
come and live with us and see how we are
and i think she'll come around and you
know it's going to take some
work but
i think to come around i mean i'm
hopeful that it will happen
well jenny this is this makes me happy
because the last time we spoke
you were done with submits parents you
were over them
but now when you speak about them you
know that anger really isn't fair so
where where does your relationship stand
with his parents well a lot has happened
so
a lot of a lot has happened and
some improvements have been made
and so now i'm just
i'm happy that at least
everyone's trying you know that it's not
a big no never won't uh
you know it's more like okay now
everyone's willing to try
and that's what makes me happy yeah a
lot of stuff is going to happen you're
going to see a whole lot of stuff
oh we've already seen a lot in the
preview ginny the moment
yeah you can see that
when you threw the chair right you were
frustrated that submit was being
indecisive marrying you
and you threw the chair how do you feel
looking back at that do you remember
if i threw a chair i don't remember
doing that
but you know it's been a while since
that happened i was just frustrated as
hell
point of no return
and that's what you saw that's what
happened
is there a world where
you won't necessarily listen to your
parents and go ahead and marry jenny or
do they have to agree for that to happen
uh
first just like you can say that's my uh
attempt you can say i always keep on
trying as but i can
and
after that like once i feel like that
like i did all my efforts to convince
them to show them how happy i am with
jenny and that's what i want in my life
and after that if they don't understand
them no point enough
i think i will go ahead and journey yeah
wow that's that's major
that's big news i'm not going anywhere
i'm here with submit whether he marries
me or not i've been with him for nine
years
already i'm not going anywhere we love
each other and
you know we'll be together no matter
what way it has to be i'll be with you
is there anything that would be a deal
breaker when it comes to your
relationship with cement
um the only thing that would be a deal
breaker would be if he just told me i'm
sorry i i will
never ever marry you and you should
probably just go back to america and
i'm gonna just
stay with my parents maybe if he said
something like that to me then yeah of
course then i would leave
the fact that you're still together as a
couple surprises so many people
so many people
did you think that you would make it
this far or be together for this long
yeah actually always yeah there was no
doubt ever in my mind and i don't think
in chinese mine still always together
yeah well overall what do you think your
your relationship represents
i'd represent uh
like you can love everybody love can
happen to anything like it
it don't see ages don't see gender it
don't see a country's boundaries
limitations
it can happen for us it doesn't
we don't really see the age difference
we don't we just
we're just in this relationship we're
together
and
we get along like we get along just fine
and so it doesn't bother us our age i
know that our age bothers people we know
that
but for us as a couple
we're fine like we have no problem with
it at all
[Music]
you